morning che I'm not gonna ask how you
are what kind of opinions you got today
I'm glad you're learning Danny I'm glad
you're the one person I'm probably going
to talk about today that's actually
learning something because that Ivy
League ginger even though he's been over
educated can't learn a damn thing
not one Danny he got outcoached for four
quarters straight period and then he
wants to put the blame for his stupid
game plan on the back of a sophomore
quarterback they drafted it around who
gives a damn like it was his fault
Zeke got the ball nine times Danny and I
want to hear was a blowout it was twenty
one to ten halftime what on earth do you
spend three first-round draft picks for
if you want to count lay out in the
number for overall pick our runner back
if you ain't gonna run the damn ball why
Danny why well Denver had the personnel
to be able to slow down the running game
and then everybody wants to put dak
Prescott in that position so Denver is
an anomaly in my opinion and I just
think it was a perfect storm of they
played the defense the way they wanted
to play it they were more physical than
Dallas they took away the run and they
made dak Prescott beat them that's all
that is called bad coaching if you have
the running game you have you force it
down their throat don't care if it's
three and out for the first two quarters
because in the third and fourth that
running game is paying you dividends
because the d-line on dimmers going to
be tired that good Danny the run defense
ain't that good for Denver but guess
what is good they're secondary let's get
our sophomore quarterback to air it out
right to a key to leave every freakin
chance we get you aren't a bad coach and
what I'm sick and tired of Danny is the
media trying to give that ginger more
credit than he deserves he is last year
was not because of him Danny it was in
spite of him it was the anti ginger they
ran the damn ball and they kept that
defense off the field you see what that
defense did when they're stuck on the
field Danny that's what they're gonna do
every day all day Danny
it's a joke I don't know why you gotta
complicate that ginger has to complicate
these kind of things it's pretty damn
simple you either lose to your strengths
or you look like an idiot
it wiped out in Denver once all college
football oh yeah let's get me in a
better mood Danny let's talk about that
let's talk about my weekend Danny that
was bring a tactic Texas had a great
showing against USC great showing
yeah great showing that's an L that's a
lot great showing it's a statement loss
you know what the statement of it's a
statement that the Marilyn Turtles sure
as hell never should have put up a
debugger on that defense that's the
showing up then you also had the bet
with the front row with Paulie and Seton
army getting Haiti that's what I'm
paying y'all in I'm bringing drugs and
paraphernalia on Friday call the police
now Danny there you go hon dollars worth
of felonies Paulie and I'm gonna call
the cops soon as you leave the parking
lot
Ohio State went up 14 nothing and all of
a sudden paulie's getting roughed up on
Twitter that they made a terrible bet
Danny I know you think I'm a conspiracy
theorist and you think I'm a little out
there as far as no I know you're out
there but let's be clear Danny this
country it's almost at war with 15
different other countries okay what this
country wants is people to rob my around
the American flag Johnny americano like
Paulie pass has been playing you want to
tell me that the Air Force Academy is
gonna cover its Michigan and that army
is gonna cover against Ohio State on the
same day against two patriotic coaches
where Porter khakis
if you don't see what is going on here I
can't help you it's obvious CIA it's
probably behind both of these covers and
now they're listening now we're all
screwed I won't even be there Friday cuz
they're gonna puppy in a black van
somewhere bring your cash on Friday
homie that's nobody said nobody said
that you couldn't pay that way yes Polly
want Shea do you want to keep it
interesting even want to keep it rolling
big boy
you know what I'm gonna bring I'm gonna
being three dice I'm gonna being three
dice with me and we're gonna play a
little game called CeeLo find me a
corner in that office and let's get
weird I know I've been asking what Cee
Lo is let's just what Paulie I'm gonna
put together my second five star of the
year and present it the che on Friday he
gonna take it or pass yes mclovin
mohegan now that Shea's giving away
money can I get in when he lets a roll
it seems like easy pickings stupid
I'll see you don't see on Friday
whatever do you know that's a Shana the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience